it skitters in the dark its insect-like
legs tapping across the marble floors as
terrified foundation researchers flee
they hear its voice the deep silky tones
of an elderly british man spouting
nonsense like the nightmare is a dream
to the nameless slug that wanders across
minefield and the remains of deer and
kings while the scientists run the
creature gains on them it's fast
impossibly fast while they still try to
escape down this darkened hallway ear
splitting containment breach sirens
blast through the air they may try to
escape but it's futile in a sense
they're already dead all they are now
is pray for the heart of darkness when
someone says the word heart there are a
lot of images that come to mind you
might think of valentine's day
heart-shaped cards and candies you might
think of heartbreak rejection loss you
might simply think of a heart in the
anatomical sense the vital organ that
pumps blood through our bodies it's
unlikely though that you would associate
the word heart with terror destruction
and countless deaths however employees
of the scp foundation might think
differently especially if they've ever
had a run-in with scp-058
much of the information about zero five
eight's discovery is highly classified
but the few details that are known paint
a chilling picture at an scp foundation
test site the day was proceeding as
usual with scientists and security
personnel going about their regular
daily tasks there was no hint of danger
in the air beyond the base level that
always comes with setting foot in an scp
foundation site at least several
researchers were performing an
experiment the specifics of which have
been expunged from all records involving
the carcass of a cow when a researcher
dr c placed his hands on the specimen
and prepared to dissect it he was
shocked to feel a pulse coming from the
supposedly dead animal dr c shared his
surprise with his colleagues but his
concerns were dismissed immediately
clearly this was a corpse he was
imagining things they said after all he
was relatively new to the job it was
probably just nerves the head researcher
dr al insisted that he take over pushing
dr c to the side dr l began to make an
incision into the animal's chest as he
did he too felt something peculiar there
was no doubt about it this dead cow had
a beating heart he looked up from his
work to tell the other researchers to
explain what he felt but by then it was
too late something horrible was already
happening with a stomach churning sound
of squishing flesh the cow's heart burst
from its chest and flopped onto the
floor it was terrifyingly large and all
the doctors jumped back from the side of
it four spindly spider-like legs poked
through the flesh of the heart and it
began to quickly skitter about the room
researchers reviewing the security
footage would later note that it didn't
just move randomly it seemed agitated
angry at being discovered and it
displayed immediate hostility towards
the scientists in the room four
tentacles next unfurled from within the
heart and stretched out into full
writhing appendages they move
frighteningly fast as the heart whipped
around the room and were coated in sharp
spines finally a stinger poked out from
the back of the heart where the whole of
the superior vena cava should be all the
scientists leapt into action with one
reaching for a scalpel and another
moving towards the door but before the
men could so much as call for help the
tentacles wrapped around them and ripped
them to shreds hearing screams coming
from the laboratory security personnel
arrived to contain the threat however
they were no match for the strange
creature that would soon be known as
scp-058 it tore through the security
team in minutes leaving their tattered
remains in its wake much to the horror
of the surviving personnel at the site
scp-058 was able to escape containment
and make its way to a neighboring town
reports of the incident said that when
the creature reached the town you could
hear the screaming for miles
scp-058 carved a path of violence
through the town attacking everything in
sight with its stinger and tentacles and
leaving a trail of strange fluid from
its stinger dozens of citizens were
killed and 70 of the buildings were
completely destroyed when agents were
dispatched to the location to retrieve
the creature they were shocked to see
the level of destruction caused by
something so small the scent of blood
and smoke filled the air and severed
limbs littered the ground alongside
splintered wood and collapsed brick the
survivors removed from the wreckage were
inconsolable only coming down once they
were given an amnesic to erase their
memory of the encounter with scp-058
they had to be given new lives as well
as there was nothing left of their old
ones scp foundation agents were only
able to capture and contain
scp-058 after it was crushed by pieces
of a building that collapsed on top of
it they found it flattened under a slab
of stone legs flailing uselessly
tentacles limp the agents were able to
safely remove the debris and bring in
the heart without any more casualties
that day once it was brought into
captivity the heart was contained for
three weeks and remained largely quiet
during that time it was almost
inconceivable that this small creature
hadn't been killed in the incident but
the foundation would soon learn that
this creature was freakishly durable it
escaped once more while being
transferred to an scp containment site
again causing injuries and death having
only experienced scp-058 in its docile
injured form the team responsible for
the transfer was unprepared for the
sheer power and violence the creature
was capable of he was able to escape an
armored car and make its way into a
forest where it eviscerated several
squirrels and rabbits or rather they
were believed to be squirrels and
rabbits the remains were too mutilated
to properly identify it was only finally
apprehended after being crushed by an
armored tank but even this didn't kill
the creature and it was transferred to
armed biocontainment area 14 where it
remains to this day there is a great
deal about scp-058 that is horrifying
but there is one attribute it has shown
in captivity that would make even the
most seasoned researcher's skin crawl
though it has no anatomical capacity for
speech no throat vocal cords or even a
respiratory system
scp-058 speaks not only does it speak
but it speaks constantly in the deep
voice of an elderly british man no one
knows who the voice might belong to or
if it belongs to anyone at all perhaps
it belongs only to scp-058 somehow as is
often the case with scps that are
capable of speech there have been
multiple attempts to interview the
creature and each time it ended in
complete disaster
the only interview with an available
transcript interview
05804 was conducted by dr johnston with
several personnel in the room for
additional security dr johnston
attempted to get at the origins of the
creature asking for its name and where
it was from the creature responded in
cryptic unsettling poetry giving answers
to simple questions with i had dreams of
the queen
wonders that lived inside the hearts of
love and silent treatments for all the
elderly that i knew were once whole
after the fourth recitation of a similar
verse from the heart personnel d-067
made a comment on the creepy nature of
its responses almost as if it was
offended by the remark
scp-058 immediately stretched a tentacle
across the room wrapped it around d-067
and lifted him into the air he began
screaming and clawing at the tentacle in
an attempt to free himself as his fellow
personnel tried to help him they grabbed
at the tentacle but found their hands
pierced and bloodied by the spikes that
cover it dr johnston commanded 058 to
let him go but it did not oblige instead
the man was crushed to death by the
tentacle and his limp body left to drop
to the floor the interview concluded
with a single statement from the
nightmarish heart the sensual violence
of lust is all the assurance you will
ever need to know the worth of life
scp-058 never seems to say anything that
has to do with the people or events
around it it speaks in the same haunting
poetic language even when it's attacking
or killing something no matter what
happens to it what is done to it or what
anyone says
scp-058 keeps talking and its tone of
voice with the pace of speech never
changing and further attempts to
interview it have been abandoned due to
the safety risk involved so what
happened to the creature often called
the heart of darkness where is it now
scp-058 is kept in an isolated
containment chamber made of reinforced
heat resistant steel with a backing of
reinforced concrete in order to placate
its bloodthirsty carnivorous tendencies
the creature is given a live cow every
three days it is uncertain how exactly
scp-058 eats given that it does not have
a mouth or stomach but every time it is
finished with a cow only bones remain
routine maintenance is conducted on a
tight schedule and the heart is never
allowed out of its containment area
under any circumstances after two
previous escapes from containment the
foundation is not taking any chances its
constant speech is recorded via audio
devices that are running at all times
out of concern for their safety and
mental health no personnel are permitted
to listen to recordings of scp-058
speaking for more than 30 minutes at a
time it is unknown what will happen to
someone who listens for longer but it
has been suggested that the consequences
could be dire if the creature ever
escapes again the containment site is
ordered to be destroyed via the
detonation of an on-site nuclear weapon
under no circumstances can it be allowed
to make its way out into the world again
even with all these precautions in place
scp-058 has been responsible for over
150 deaths at its current containment
site there are some at the foundation
who have campaigned for scp-058 to be
terminated believing that there is more
harm than good done by keeping it alive
however all attempts to terminated have
so far failed no matter how much
physical trauma the heart suffers it
does not seem to be able to be killed it
can only be incapacitated for a short
time there is a classic horror story by
edgar allan poe called the telltale
heart in it a man murders an old man and
buries his body beneath the floorboards
of his home there even though the old
man is certainly dead
the murderer swears he can hear the
beating of the heart coming up through
the floorboards no matter what he does
to quiet the sound he cannot escape it
and is eventually driven mad by the
incessant beating of the dead man's
heart
scp-058 may not be a man's heart a human
heart or even a real heart at all
however just like the tell-tale heart it
continues to impossibly beat no matter
how hard anyone tries to stop it the
steady thump of its pulse haunts the scp
foundation a grim reminder that there is
something within its walls that can and
will kill everyone it can if given the
chance it couldn't be destroyed by
collapsed buildings an armored tank or
an army of experts and the contingency
plan of a nuclear blast is not even
guaranteed to work it is entirely
possible that once the facility has been
laid waste and all the staff have been
incinerated and the smoke has finally
cleared the heart of darkness will still
be there still beating still talking and
still
killing now go check out
scp-1981 reagan cut up while talking and
scp-2662 cthulhu for more of the
strangest anomalies contained by the scp
foundation